it was their last ever live performance
from up high the beatles playing on a
rooftop on savile row ken wharf who was
21 and a policeman back then got a call
to try to shut it down i literally went
into the number three behind me and sort
of ascended the stairs and all i
remember was ringo starr in that sort of
tangerine coat and i thought this is the
best thing that's ever gonna happen to
me in the police service now we're going
to take the beatles and i'll be quiet oh
you've enjoyed in our conversation how
the band made it to that moment is
dissected in director peter jackson's
three-part documentary capturing the
recording sessions for the let it be
album we should do the show in a place
we're not allowed to do it getting
forcibly ejected
sound engineer dave harry's helped
record the album
they weren't very happy with the fact
that the studio wasn't completed and
running properly as they were told for a
start i think they'd invested a fair bit
of money in that and that was a shame
because they deserve
they deserve better their harmonies you
know of all the harmonies were brilliant
memory can be a funny thing and there is
a certain mythology to how the beatles
broke up that we all think we know
which basically goes everything was
glorious until the end of the 60s but by
the time they recorded let it be
they'd fallen out and they didn't want
to make music together and even sir paul
mccartney said that that was what he
thought had happened until he saw the
footage
[Music]
very very good
but the third one what is it looking for
at home till last looking for a blast
from the past it wasn't anywhere near as
miserable as we've been led to believe
and um they were still a sort of
functioning coherent band who liked each
other the documentary's just grinding to
a halt grinding to a whole something
it's taking off
the footage gives every beatles fan the
ending they'd wanted
me down
four young friends who aren't at each
other's throats but who are laughing and
enjoying making music together katy
spencer sky news